remember this series about time we got
back to this what's up guys my name is
Cherno this is a series in which I'm
taking one of the first games that I
ever made probably the first game that I
ever made called Genesis I made it for
let them down like a 48 hour game Jam
back in the day in 2012 in 48 hours it's
a game where you walk around and you
like
like there's women there and yeah but
I've explained it before so what we're
doing is we're remaking it from the
original Java code which is like this is
eclipse this is Java this is my youth it
feels like my childhood and we're
putting on our adult pants on and we're
we're remaking it in C plus plus because
we're adults now and we're mature no
hate to anyone who uses and loves Java
it's
that's okay so last episode we just
talked about like Global variables and
how to make them because we had like
this um
kind of sprite situation we were like
how do we just make Sprites and header
files it ended up becoming like a video
an in-depth video on like how to make
Global variables and C plus in the first
place if that interests you check it out
link will be up there today I'm gonna
really really strive to actually make
the game
um because I'm realizing that this is
going to wind up being one of those
series that just goes on for years and I
I'm very good at doing that and I don't
want to do that in this case so let's
dive into the code and let's uh talk
about what we're going to do today now
what I wanted to do today
um was actually spend some time
like in the level system because at the
moment by the way like where we're at at
the moment is this let me just run this
I can't actually run this because uh I
was giving examples so let's just try
and get rid of those Sprites try and run
it uh yeah so like this is where we're
at at the moment which basically let me
just zoom in here uh which basically
like we have some Sprites rendering
we've got the player Sprite that we're
able to access from the Sprites here
we've got this torch on top you can see
it's compositing nicely and discarding
like the pixels that are supposed to be
transparent all that stuff's kind of
working
um so the next logical step there are a
lot of potential next steps but the next
step that I want to make is like why
don't we now that we can render
individual Sprites like this let's
render a whole level and because we are
remaking a game that already exists uh
that's a lot easier to do because like
for example like we have I think it's
called ocean right yeah this is like the
main level like we actually have it here
right this is the level so it's not like
we have to like go ahead and design
levels now or you know Place random
Sprites or do anything like ridiculous
like that no like we should just be able
to read in this texture and then use it
to place the right type of tile in the
right spot just like the original game
used to do it and so that's what I'm
that's what my plan is for today and of
course we've got a lot of the code that
we need here
um the screen class I believe has like
you know render tile which again will
basically just do a little copy from the
Sprite sheets pixels into like the the
entire screens pixels
um thereby you know rendering that
Sprite at a particular location on our
screen this kind of X offset y offset is
important because that's essentially the
camera that you know the level might be
this big but obviously you know at any
given moment we'll be inside like we'll
have like a window into that world and
we only want to we don't want to render
anything that's outside of this view
only tiles that are inside this view
should be rendered and so it's important
to kind of also set up this x offset y
offset which is essentially the camera
and you can see that basically takes our
I guess the X position and the wipers
are the surrender mod but it's the same
concept run a tile it'll take like the
exposition the Y position of the tire
like in the level and basically kind of
offset it into view space I guess so
this is kind of like World space style
coordinate and this is view space in the
sense that this is relative to that
camera's offset thus it's actually on
the screen now and if it's not on the
screen uh you know if the I guess the XT
and whatever ends up being either less
than zero or greater than like what we
can see somewhere
um yeah so like I see it's a little bit
hard to see like what width was I
thought width was somewhere here width
is like the width of the screen I guess
yeah it'll it would be like you know we
have a an array of integers here which
represents every pixel that we have like
that makes up the graphics in our window
and this would be the width of that so
if our width was I think it's like um
900 I I think yeah it's 300 times three
so in terms of actual pixels we're
rendering we're rendering 300 of them uh
wide but the window ends up being scaled
up by three so it's 900 by you know
whatever that is 900 by 180 times three
um but anyway back in random tile you
can see that if it's kind of if this
like potential pixel we want to render
is actually outside of the bounds we
just break we don't continue doing it
I'm a little bit interested in why
there's no culling like here before we
even start entering the for Loop
um especially because like for example
this break that happens here like
there's a YT check here that could have
easily been done in this Loop and then
we wouldn't have to enter this Loop
because obviously YT is kind of known up
up here for X2 you have to do it here
because it's obviously this is the loop
that determines x t but this could have
been done here but also even just being
like hey like you know this is this
bright like position is completely
outside of the bounds of what's visible
on the screen like which could be
determined pretty quickly because that's
the other thing right like this will
check um I don't know if I should get
into detail now about this but I'm doing
it so whatever XP and YP is basically
like I assume the top left coordinate of
this kind of tile so like this is the
tile it's like well I think it's 16 by
16 right so this is the tile 16 by 16
pixels but this is like the top left
coordinate and then we're going to go
through like the Y which will make let's
just color code this blue we're going to
go kind of down this way but then
internally in the loop we'll say orange
is X we're going to go across this way
right so we'll end up kind of going down
that way y will increment and then the x
coordinate will just go across like this
and so obviously if we know the size of
the Sprite and we do it 16 we could just
be like hey you know if XP in the first
place is less than zero but not just
less than zero because it has to be if
XP plus 16 is less than zero because
obviously if the screen cuts off here
it's possible that we actually have a
little bit of the kind of tile showing
and we do want to render that
um so you kind of have to do a little
bit of math here but you could easily
just see like does this fit onto the
screen up here and then not even go into
the for Loops which I assume would be
like probably worth doing
um because I don't think that like this
is a bit annoying to me because you're
kind of going through and uh you know
past me is kind of going through and
actually basically being like hey is
this pixel out of bounds hey is this is
this pixel out of bounds hey is this
pixel out of bounds instead of just
being like hey I know the rectangle of
what I'm drawing let me just check like
Each corner ultimately Corners is just a
good way to think about it but really
you're just checking kind of two planes
or whatever you're checking to see is it
outside of like the kind of Y of bounds
or is it outside of like the the X kind
of horizontal bounds and that's it and
then you don't have to do anything in
here because you can kind of do that
ahead of time you still do need the kind
of per pixel check because as I
mentioned if you're halfway out like
this uh then you still do want to render
a few pixels and so you kind of want to
discard these and probably like continue
or whatever but this is a break anyway
and that's why it's doing minus Sprite
size because it breaks if it's
completely uh if this Sprite is
completely out of bounds whereas if it's
partially out of bounds it will this
won't be true and and then we end up
clipping it which is why we get some
weird behaviors anyway lots of stuff
going on but before we dive into it and
start porting this to C plus plus I want
to thank brilliant.org sponsoring this
video brilliant.org is an amazing
website filled with lots and lots of
really really high quality courses on
various stem topics math is an integral
part of see what I did there math is an
integral part of computer science like
you know this kind of stuff that we're
doing here you need to have like some
kind of fundamental math knowledge
people ask me all the time if math is
important for programming and it really
does depend what kind of programming
you're doing but overall I would say
yeah absolutely and brilliant.org is
just such a good place to learn math all
the way down to their Everyday Math
course which is fantastic if you've like
never done math before if you're scared
of math that course is just such a
beautiful gentle introduction that will
kind of let you appear into the vast
world of math but then as you progress
through your journey you can go to
things like linear algebra which is very
very important for graphics and games
and along those lines progress into
calculus which also is very very
important and quite frequently used and
the way that brilliant teaches you this
stuff is extremely visual it's very
interactive they'll give you these
widgets to play with so you can see how
the numbers affect what's actually
happening and they'll also continually
quiz you to to make sure that you're
actually learning and retaining the
information the best thing about
brilliant is you can get started for
free they have a 30-day free trial just
go to brilliant.org the channel just
have a browse through the courses and
check them out for yourselves and if you
do go on to like it brilliant have been
nice enough to offer the first 200
subscribers 20 off an annual membership
huge thank you as always to brilliant
for sponsoring this video alright so I
kind of want to stop talking about this
stuff now and start uh implementing it
um because again there's there's quite a
lot of stuff going on here which is
really really cool because this was like
uh you know this kind of code and this
kind of way of doing things was really
heavily inspired by notch making um I
think it was Minicraft which is like a
game that he made for a lot of dare back
in the day like London 24 maybe off from
the top of my head but he decided to
make like a really really retro Style
game I didn't go quite as retro as he
did because he had like some kind of
limited color palette from what I know
and he did some fancy things that were
completely unnecessary but he kind of
imposed those limitations on himself
just to make it more interesting I guess
I didn't go quite that far but a lot of
the stuff that you're are seeing here
like is really inspired from that kind
of code and I had kind of you know back
then in my programming journey I really
like I tried making games like that a
lot because I was so interested in like
the kind of the Retro way I guess of
doing things and just like putting every
pixel onto the screen manually you know
like yourself which is what's going on
here we're rendering like to an image
pixel by pixel and so like all of this
code like I'd just write stuff like this
over and over again like in my free time
trying to make games from scratch all
the time and so when it came down to let
him down like this kind of code like it
was just ingrained in me and memorized
so like I think a lot of this stuff is
definitely similar to like how Notch uh
kind of made his uh low Fidelity
graphics with a little bit of my own
twists I guess
um kind of thrown in there uh okay
anyway I promised we'd talk about the
level so let's kind of get on to that um
so the first thing I kind of want to do
is load these images I think that we
already have yeah levels are here so
first and foremost let's go about
actually loading an image so we have an
image class in Walnut which is kind of
the library that um IRA right the way
using for this series uh this image
class though what it will do is it will
you can see it's going to read in the
pixel data if we provide it and it's
going to read it in in the right format
here and then it's going to actually
allocate memory on the GPU and upload it
to the GPU then free the CPU side data
this is not really what we want because
I want the image to be just accessible
on the CPU and in fact we don't really
need any GPU side images apart from the
one that we write to so what I'm going
to do is I'm basically going to copy
this I'm just going to copy this whole
block we're going to make a level class
again I'm not going to this is like a
game not really an engine so I'm not
going to worry about like making a
custom image class or you know like um I
mean you know a good thing to do would
probably have been to go into you know
walnuts like image class and then be
like hey why don't we have like a
particular configuration for this image
class where it's like CPU only so it
doesn't even upload anything to Vulcan
but it just loads the image we have like
an array of pixels that we can then use
like you know kind of I guess you know
side so like kind of you know our C plus
plus side that never hits the GPU that
would have been good since Walnut
doesn't provide that though I didn't
write it here
um I might do it in the future but let's
just like ignore that and we'll just do
it ourselves so namespace Genesis I
think is where we're in class level
again I'm this is like ultimately a port
with some improvements I guess so I'm
just going to read this I don't think
this is ever used
um I guess what is it Control G or
something control yeah I still remember
no that's not it alt shift it's like
work with uh references workspace
control shift JLS close
um yeah there's nothing for that and
this yeah so this is used right so we're
not actually using this Constructor
anywhere so I'm not gonna use that one
this is the one that we have though it
takes in a path then it does this so
again I'm gonna kind of be porting that
largely which is good because that means
that we can kind of focus on not like
how did we do things necessarily let's
do a uh let's do a um file system path
but we can just focus on um you know the
actual kind of C plus plus code and how
we want to structure that so it's a nice
exercise I think should we have a
Destructor maybe maybe not so let's just
create implementation uh whoops I didn't
do anything in here so include level
namespace Genesis that means we can get
rid of this guy
um now we I guess you know we'll we'll
have like a copy of the file path that's
just good to do for even like simple
things like debugging
um I'll just get rid of this uh so let's
go ahead and set that up because it's
nice to be able to like inspect your
level and be like you know as an
inspector in the debugger and be like oh
that's this level like this is the file
that it's from so we'll do that and then
uh if I paste in of course I've lost
that but if we paste in the code that we
copied here
this will basically load the um uh load
the actual image file Let's uh we're not
going to do sdb image implementation
because it'll be included in this image
so we can just do this
and that gets statically linked into
here okay
so let's see here that's gonna be a bit
annoying giving this to sdbi actually if
it's a file system path I think because
it wants a cons Char and this if you do
pathos Esther I'm going to give you wide
characters so you have to dot string and
then dot C string and that's a bit
annoying but anyway it's not HDR so I
can get rid of this Branch
um this we can just pull up to here
yeah so we'll I think we'll have to do
basically uh path string or whatever and
we'll have to do path dot string and
then we'll do dot C string the reason
why is again you can't do this because
this is the wrong format
um and if we do dot string.c string
like this
um that's not it'll compile but the
problem is that you're kind of
I don't know this temporary object
should be good because this will
obviously return a copy
um let's say I think it's this one you
can say it's not returning a reference
it's returning a copy and so what it
means is that you're kind of creating a
temporary object and then you're getting
the pointer to something that is owned
by the temporary object and so this like
honestly I can never tell you whether or
not that's actually going to crash and I
think it might depend on the compiler or
whatever but this is not a good thing to
do just because like you have no
permanent object like this is the thing
that owns the pointer and the memory
that you're referencing here and so
since it's kind of like oh you're just
using the pointer which is just an
integer it might destroy that object and
then it will crash because you're trying
to reference memory that you don't have
so I would always bring it down to an L
value again it's not going to matter
because this is um you know this is
returning a value anyway so it's not
like where it's not like it's returning
a reference then we're copying it it's
kind of like that anyway and we have to
do that because again these parts are
usually wide kind of strings right and
we're kind of converting it into just a
normal string by doing Dot string and
then C string so probably a long
explanation but that's the way it is
we'll try it we'll Force four channels I
think ah well no I think there are three
channels let's just do three channels
because these images don't have any
Alpha and again what what by by putting
a number here because you can just leave
this as zero and it might even have a no
it doesn't by putting uh it here
um you're basically saying like make
sure that it is in that format kind of
we have kind of three channels
definitely because otherwise it will
just it'll return like well regardless
it will tell you how many channels the
image actually has which is what this is
and then that's you base basically being
like I want this memory buffer to be in
this particular format and so it's good
because it can just Pat it out so for
example if this was an RGB texture but I
wanted it in rgba I can write four here
and it will add an alpha Channel you
know
um so it's quite useful
uh width and height
um where are we using that here let's
see so
no because we have a width and height
but it looks like our load level from
file probably sets that okay so low
level from files what does that I guess
I should probably do that here as well
let's make a void load level from file
and we can pass this in sure this will
just clean up the Constructor a bit load
level from file
um okay with so width and height we need
to set as well that's the thing un32
width I always like setting these to
defaults because otherwise we'll get
random memory there before this code
runs so we've got that set up now
allocate memory set data and free so
free
um we're probably gonna keep this for
the duration of the because what happens
here or do we not oh we don't okay so
what we could do here is like what this
function does
um and it's always like a little bit
harder to tell with Java because
obviously it's a garbage collected
language and so it can be like a little
bit difficult to tell like whether or
not certain things are like you know
what is their lifetime because nothing
really gets explicitly deleted but
basically what what um what's Happening
Here is we're loading the image and then
we're actually copying the entire image
kind of buffer into uh this tiles array
right so that's what this function does
if we take a look at it so we can give
it like a start RGB array the RGB um
pixels are written here so we pass in an
array and that's destination for this
and that's like the region we copy
basically so we're actually copying all
of them into uh this kind of integer
array called tiles so let's kind of
replicate that behavior I guess so we'll
make uh it's an integer so we'll make it
a uint here don't really have units in
Java at least back then we didn't uh
anyway we'll make a pointer here called
tiles again copying it directly we'll
set it to null now I believe it probably
allocates it here I don't know why grass
is a thing we don't ever use grass here
just creates it oh no we do oh okay
okay we'll set that up I don't know why
that just doesn't happen here though
okay whatever
oh I'll say less
um so we'll do so this is obviously once
we know the size of the level based on
the pixels we can allocate enough
integers for them uh and then we can
just do
um and actually like with this three
channels thing I'll end up doing
whatever is done here and I think it
actually might be four
because yeah because I'm patting this
out with FF here anyway
when I did the comparison like I'm not
doing that which would be the equivalent
obviously if we add zeros there because
the data didn't exist but like the other
thing that's important though
really important is and why I'll
actually make this for is because
obviously a un-32t is four bytes and if
you have a una T and you cast it to a
32t or copy it if you don't copy it like
if this means we can just do a simple
mem copy because we know that this is
going to be equivalent to this in fact
we don't even have to do a mem copy we
could just take that buffer yeah it like
it really doesn't make sense like in
Java it does but here it really doesn't
make sense I think to set it up this way
because you could just be like okay I
I'm going to interpret this as un32t and
just set this to be tiles and then just
free the image you know at the end so
basically we'll go into um
or make a Destructor called level so
let's actually do it this way I guess
because that would be a little bit more
optimal we're not creating a buffer for
no reason
and tiles is kind of that buffer
um so we could just do this basically
um because this is obviously going to be
in the right format and it's basically
the same thing as what we were doing
here so let's do that and then obviously
for the grass like whatever's going on
here
um we'll have to replicate so let's do
grass and grass equals new unit 32t uh
worth times height now you could make
these vectors uh the advantage there is
just that it you don't have to free them
but I like you know this is deliberately
written in kind of a raw a raw way like
this whole you know this whole game so
I'm Gonna Keep it a little bit more more
raw and just use basic kind of simple
loss Pages not kind of use
um vectors where they're not strictly
speaking needed of course we're going to
still use vectors because they're used
quite a bit we need some kind of dynamic
arrays like hold the entities and stuff
but for like tiles where it's very fixed
um we're just going to use this okay so
that's it I think
um oh and the grass needs to be
populated with random stuff doesn't it
so this is us going through the grass
let's just copy this for Loop to be
honest uh where should I do that I guess
I'll do that here same as the Java code
so we'll go through uh so grass at
length so that's the thing in Java we
actually have a length for arrays in
simple plus we don't unless we keep
track of it ourselves now we know that
the length is going to be width times
height though so we can just use that
um
uh and that way we don't have to have an
extra size or use an STD array or the
STD array like or a vector we'd use a
vector in this case because we'd want it
to be Heap allocated
um okay so grass I equals uh random next
into eight so Random Walnut
random uh ins
I guess it can be a uint oh it's it's a
U.N sum this is a unit but you can just
do random range I think
or am I thinking of Hazel
I don't know like is that a thing or is
it not it's okay if it's not but it
would be nice if it was
um okay let's just do oh we do have a
Min and Max here don't we okay so we can
just do units and then we can just be
zero and I guess eight I don't know if
that's inclusive or not uh Max minus one
plus one looks like it is so let's just
keep that I'm not sure if the Java one
is inclusive though so like does that
include bound it's exclusive okay so I
don't know I feel like this should be
seven then in that case uh okay cool so
now let's um like we have that basically
here right so let's go ahead and see if
we can uh if that works so we'll go back
to like game
um I'm gonna make a shared pointer here
called level
I guess I guess like I guess it could be
a unique pointer it's just unique
pointers it's so annoying to pass around
that I end up making things shared
shared pointers quite a lot
um the real difference is honestly just
like performance because SharePoint is
uh you know their reference counter
they're a little bit more kind of
there's a little bit of overhead there
compared to Unique pointers nothing
you'd ever notice in this context but
still like it might be a good habit to
get into let's get rid of some of the
sum this was from the global variables
episode just some printing but let's go
ahead and make unique level and we'll
basically pop that into we'll pop in the
file path which is res levels and I
guess ocean.png is really the only level
we ended up using in the actual game so
there you go so go to level now um so
what I'm going to do is I'm just going
to put a breakpoint like I guess here
just after this function because I want
to inspect tiles I guess I can put it
here
um and just see whether or not that
actually was loaded with integers and
what format they're in and stuff like
that
so let's see
um okay so it didn't crash which is good
and there's tiles and now uh what you
can do is you can go to watch you can
pop this in just paste it in and then
you can say how many you want because
obviously it's a pointer so the kind of
debugger doesn't necessarily know that
is as a buffer is this an array I mean
it really tried to probably could but to
it it's just like an unsigned endpoint
huh so it can just be like okay show 100
or a thousand of these right and it's
going to do that and if you right click
you can be like I want this in
hexadecimal because it'll be easier to
read and then you can see uh you know
what we're greeted with now we're going
to see a lot of ocean here because
that's what the image looks like right
if we open the image it's mostly ocean
so it can be a little bit hard to see
um but I'm assuming that it's more than
just this but also importantly you can
see that you can see that it's kind of
padded out here with ffs at the front
and then FF which again I don't know if
it's padded up that could just be it
could just be a you know a 32-bit kind
of PNG well uh an rgba PNG in which case
it's got that Alpha Channel there but
yeah that's kind of it
um let's maybe do a hundred thousand I
don't know if 100 000 is but I'm just
going yeah so you can see some of them
are pink for example that's pink right
there that's uh purple like a darker
pink so I didn't actually think we had
those
like where are you saying pink and
purple
that's a bit weird I could have gone off
the edge like I don't know how much how
big is it yeah this probably isn't that
big is it I like this level
uh what is it 128 by 128 yeah so that's
I guess that's too much because 128 by
128 is only 16 384. so I've clearly gone
too far hence why we're seeing weird
values so let's just do 16 000
um and this should be basically
everything
and again I'm just kind of looking
through to see like okay we've got some
white here which is good because there's
a lot of white in the image
um you know we've got a lot of that that
kind of blue here
um which is very specific we've got this
color as well which looks like some kind
of green but a dark green yeah so that
would be this this kind of stuff so it
looks like our images is here which is
excellent so it's nice to just kind of
you know I think John Carmack was even
saying this like on a podcast maybe like
the Lex Friedman podcast or something
but he was talking about how like a lot
of the times he'll write a function and
then he'll like he won't necessarily
test it by like just continuing to write
the program and hoping it works but
he'll actually put break points in and
go through everything and make sure the
values are what he expects
um and that's something that I like
doing as well just kind of going through
you know like like I did just then and
be like okay is this kind of correct
what are the numbers it's it's nice
because it just gives you a bit more
information rather than you know let's
just say that it was kind of slightly in
the wrong format and then we'd go ahead
and write the rest of the program and
then when we get to like you know trying
to actually render tiles or whatever and
obviously the way that we render tiles
like there's a get tile function here
that will check the color and then it
won't be working and we'll be like oh
why not and then we'll discover oh it's
actually in the wrong format and it's
not this you know instead of doing all
of that it's nice to just be able to
validate what you've written and make
sure that it kind of works okay I really
want to get some tiles on the screen
though and then we'll probably end it
for today
um so let's kind of make a render
function I'm not gonna I'm not exactly
going to uh worry about the camera or
anything like that let's just go through
and try and render some stuff
um
I want to I guess we'll probably have to
pass in the renderer or is that a global
theme did we make this a global thing
I don't remember if we wanted to because
we can draw Sprite oh we can't even draw
it at a particular location can we so
we'll have to implement that this might
be harder than I thought
um but renderer did we because game has
renderer right
and this is technically static so we
could go through here but let's just
pass it in maybe so I'll grab this kind
of shared pointer well we'll grab this
renderer and then let's do uh in on
update I'll do level render
and then we'll pass in the renderer
and then if we go to here
let's have the little renderer so this
is kind of like us passing in the screen
everywhere in Java and again you don't
really have to do this like I maybe
would even make this static just because
it kind of makes sense to
um but
yeah I don't know
it's just one of those things where you
could do it like so many different ways
and it's not gonna matter like it's
honestly not gonna matter especially for
something this size
um but this is fine like it's nice to do
this just in case you have multiple
renderers again for different viewports
or whatever which again for this game
you're not going to need that but again
maybe I did I did say at one point maybe
we will make a multiplayer version of
this which would be funny but yeah okay
so basically what what we can do is
let's just go through
um like we could go through like the
whole world again that's going to be
stupid to do here let me get rid of this
um because like we don't want to render
every single tile but if we did go
through the whole world we could be like
you know let's get like the a particular
tile right
um so let's do
tiles I for example and also the way
you'd want to do this you can still do
it in a single Loop obviously like this
but it makes a little bit more sense if
you do a nested Loop so that you have
wine X separated but you can do it you
can just do
um you know imod with I divided by width
to get X and Y respectively if you just
have a single dimensional coordinate but
this is better
so we'll do tiles X Plus y times width
so that is the kind of the color code
right so tile ID I'll say that's that's
the tile ID now and so what we could do
is be like renderer you know uh we can
do draw Sprite the problem is again X
index y indexes within a Sprite sheet
um so we could be like Sprites you know
I want to draw sprites grass but this
would only be grass everywhere
um which was a bit unfortunate so uh and
what is this
oh we didn't did we not make that work
let's maybe instead of doing this so
we'll do the Sprite rendering we'll do
the actual tile rendering next episode
it's already uh dragging on and we still
have a lot of systems to write here but
I just want to see if I can because I
can draw these particular Sprites but
can I just draw like individual pixels
or even get access to the image buffer
because if I could do that then we could
just actually draw our our level which
would be good so there's the get image
buffer so if I go on to
level
um we can do renderer get image buffer
which I'll do up here so now we actually
have a pointer to that block of memory
this out that is our image buffer and we
could just be like X Plus y times width
uh equals tile ID right so that would
fill it with that particular pixel's
color now
um a few notes here if this goes out of
bounds that's very bad uh we can ask the
size though I believe get with and get
height so I would do like a little kind
of if if um X well X is not going to be
less than zero but it's possible the
level width is bigger than the amount of
pixels we have on the screen I don't
think that's it's 128 by 128 so I don't
think that's the case here but again you
need to check technically so the way we
do that is we basically be like if uh
you know if x is greater than like
renderer get with then I would break
because it's obviously only gonna it's
only gonna keep getting larger and same
here like if Y is greater than get
height and break because obviously it's
only going to keep getting bigger so
there's no point kind of continuing look
at me I'm running this like Java now
like single line that's how I used to
write it in Java okay so we're filling
that up now uh now we just need to make
sure that we're not doing anything after
that otherwise we won't see it so in
game uh yeah as long as we do this last
basically it should be fine so we should
probably see some pixels on the screen
now that represent the map that we've
just loaded
uh and we do not so that went well
um
I wonder why oh we do update image we
need to update image puts it on the GPU
and we need to do that first okay
wonderful so you can see what that looks
like here um the reason why it looks
like this is because obviously uh when
I'm doing this in into the when I'm
writing into the image which is the
buffer I need to make sure that I use
the buffers width here with this
coordinate and not um M width which is
the level so when I when I read or write
to M tiles I use I use it's kind of
width obviously and when I'm reading and
writing to the buffer which is the image
buffer I need to use the actual width of
the kind of image buffer because what
kind of it's a single dimensional array
but we're trading it like it's a
two-dimensional coordinate all right and
there you have it so we have the image
that we kind of made here or that we
loaded in the level uh just being like
blittered I guess copied onto our screen
like this and so the idea now is to
actually read the kind of tile ID and
just draw the 16x16 kind of tile at that
particular coordinate and then also have
a camera system that makes sure that
relative to where the player's position
is we see like a view into all of those
tiles and also don't waste time you know
rendering tiles that are outside of the
bounds because that especially at this
level like where it's like every pixels
being like it's it would be very
performance intensive and it would
really really slow down our code
um or our entire program our game you
can kind of get away with like for
something like this if you just use
falcon or opengl because it will kind of
it won't bother rasterizing those pixels
anyway it'll just kind of clip them uh
once it sees that the vertices are out
of that kind of negative one to one
range you can kind of just almost not
worry about it um but with something
like this you definitely have to so yeah
hope you guys enjoyed this video
uh please hit the like button if you did
next time as I mentioned we're going to
go through and we're going to actually
like draw the tiles and hopefully make
up this kind of level World with the
camera and all of that stuff let me know
if you're enjoying this series uh it's
it's quite fun for me because I'm
revisiting stuff that I wrote like
what like 11 years ago I guess don't
forget to check out brilliant Dog
Channel link will be in description
below and I will see you next time
goodbye